Hello.
Hi, uh, very nice to meet you all. Uh,
my name is Patrick Gritzka. I am a senior
solutions architect at Cloudflare, specifically
covering our,
uh, developer platform.
Um,
our developer platform is essentially
focused around offerings like workers.
It is a
serverless edge-based, um,
basically compute offering that, that gives you both
storage as well as, uh,
workflow and compute primitives. Um.
What I'll be presenting to you today is
essentially a session around
building MCP servers.
Um,
we have worked with a lot of companies to help them
bring their first production MCP servers,
uh, live this year. Um,
we did, we worked with a large batch of companies
earlier in about April or March
of this year to,
to push things forward in a nice wave. Um,
we'll, we'll start, I guess, at the very
start in terms of
what is MCP.
Uh, MCP was defined late last
year by Anthropic.
Uh, MCP is model context
protocol.
Um,
MCP servers essentially are
acting as almost like a
similar to, to what you might have
looked at for APIs in the past
as a means of
allowing interoperability between
siloed data among different
applications. Um, what MCPs
now serve as
are essentially an interface that allows
for
your LLM based agents
to interact with.
That otherwise siloed data.
So, if you want to have an agent
be able to
update a Slack message,
update a Jira ticket,
update uh any of this content that's
available across
specific services,
an MCP server can act as
essentially
that interface
for providing tools,
and a tool will be,
um, depending on the complexity of it,
it can be something as simple as surfacing
up again.
An existing API,
but it can also be more complex. It can have
more custom logic, and it can also
have more flexibility because you can still
rely on an LLM to
not only
call an individual.
You know, an individual API,
but to actually make plans and to
to really execute more complex tasks.
So
We believe that
we have a pretty compelling offering and way for
you to launch MCP servers
that allow you to both move quickly,
maintain maintain developer velocity,
while minimalizing operational overhead.
Um, I think there are some varying
opinions in terms of
what the future looks like in terms of how many MCP
servers organizations may run.
Um, we.
Uh, just of, of our own kind of cloud flare,
uh, remote MCP offerings have,
I think, about 13 of them that run, run the
gamut from
observability MCPs that surface up your
logs to your coding agents to documentation
ones, to ones that even offer up,
um, some of our services like radar as
availability. And
I think there will be an aspect where
giving customers the ability to make.
Granular choices in terms of what features
and functionality they want to incorporate into their
workloads is probably going to be
a bit of a winning strategy there.
Um.
Touching back on our initial demo day earlier
this year, uh, companies like PayPal,
Stripe, Webflow, Block, Atlassian,
uh, all worked with us to launch their first MCP
servers. Um,
it's also why
we feel very confident saying that we're one of the
fastest places where you can build an MCP
server. Um, PayPal worked with us
to within 3 days go from a concept
of what can they deliver
to essentially having a production ready MCP
server for their invoicing scenarios.
Um, in terms of
what you get with an MCP server on our platform,
uh, you can use our agents SDK.
An MCP server is not a
kind of packaged product. It is built on
top of our primitives. So
you'll
essentially your MCP server will be an abstraction
on top of,
uh, services like our durable objects.
Our durable objects offer Serverless
compute tied with stateful storage.
So that allows you to have both scale
to zero compute for
the actual,
um,
the actual calls that are made to your, to your server,
while still maintaining a state full back end
that is able to maintain
both your short-term and long-term memory for
your ongoing conversations.
Um,
this also runs on our distributed architecture,
so you get the benefit of,
uh, Having a single global
data plane. So regardless of if you have
users coming in from
the United States,
Europe, Asia, um,
without having to manage separate control clusters,
uh, manage separate updates across regions
or availability zones, uh, you get the benefit
of having localized compute for each of them
and localized as well as storage for their
conversations, uh, without,
again, operational overhead.
Um MCP
is,
well, many of you probably already
have, have many conversations around MCP,
but part of the reason for the excitement
is that this feels like a new channel. This
feels like a means of now making
services available through essentially
agentic interactions. It feels like
if companies, if, you
know, whether those are public services
like
um,
Like, you know, even public sector,
uh, interfaces, or even if those are, uh,
more like e-commerce, uh, interactions,
it feels like
if companies aren't surfacing up
their products, their offerings,
their means of
completing conversions and completing transactions
and surfacing up information through an MCP
server, they may be passed
by because to a degree, this is, this
feels like.
How information is going to be surfaced up through this
interface that seems to be
kind of encroaching on what search has traditionally,
um,
search has traditionally covered.
OK.
You know. OK.
So, here, uh, I have just a simple
chat interface that plugs into one of our MCP
servers.
Um,
what this MCP server is doing is
it is interacting with,
um,
within the durable object. It has access to
all of our services.
So it is able to make use of services
like our
Um,
Like our browser rendering services,
in order to actually interact with web pages.
So, um, your agents
may not always have clearly defined APIs
that they can call and interact with,
um,
but using options like
essentially browser rendering, which gives you
a headless browser and allows you to then
Uh, both scrape content from
it in HTML, Markdown,
JSON format,
but also have puppeteer-style interactions
in terms of
clicking buttons, entering text
content. Um, you're able to, to
actually, again, interface with pages and
allow your agent to plan interactions
without needing to
beforehand.
Fully, fully,
essentially have, have API key
access to, to the system you're interacting with.
Um, here,
uh, specifically, I'm just going to go ahead and ask
it to
make a booking for me for a
given time slot.
So this, uh, this interface is just meant to be
a little
showcase of, uh, court availabilities
across
courts, let's say 123456
for a given park.
I'm just going to go ahead and ask it
to.
OK.
I don't know what
Uh And
I can do a little bit of a showcase here,
so. Here,
uh, we can see that it's, it's passing in
the information that's available.
Um, I can also,
uh,
uh.
I. Um
There. OK,
so that should finally come through,
um.
In terms of like,
interesting bits, that largely just
is meant to showcase that you can
have these interactions, not just go through
tailored paths, like a path that's well defined
through an API
but you can actually have your agents
dynamically kind of pull in
what is the structure of a page
and
make it, make it actually interact with a, with a
given UI interface. Um,
in terms of,
like, Underlying value
that you get from the solution.
Um,
it really does in my mind, come down to
the fact that like a durable object is going to be able
to offer you
Remarkable horizontal scalability to where
each uh each session, so each,
sorry,
each of those like little
Each of those interfaces that come up for
a chat is tied to a single durable
object instance.
A durable object can instantiate
across IDs,
so programmatically,
every conversation that we're having
gets its own sharded compute, sharded
storage,
so you don't have to worry about
suddenly scaling that out when there's more traffic
coming in. You don't have to worry about scaling
out your, you know,
memory and storage when.
The millionth conversation has started to
become because that is automatically kind of horizontally
scaling across your newly instantiated
resources.
Um, it also gives you a decent bit of flexibility
where that memory is still tied to that individual
durable object instance.
So if you're looking to have
conversations tied to a single user,
you can, you can have that easily implemented
by having them tied to a single ID,
but you can also have multiple individuals
interacting with a single agent conversation
just by tying their.
Essentially a conversation back to the same ID
so you get the the ability and flexibility
to have
various interaction patterns,
while also having an easy
kind of routing method if you do decide
to make multi-agenttic kind
of interfaces for
having them interact with, with separate
instances. Um,
yeah, if there are any questions that kind of
come up throughout, like,
uh, um, I don't know, implementation
or, or approach, um,
There's quite a bit of content that we have
regarding um various SDKs
and various tooling that we have to improve uh agent,
agent workloads. So, uh,
beyond just browser rendering, we now have also dynamic
worker loaders.
Uh, dynamic worker loaders allow you
to dynamically provide, whether it's
JavaScript or TypeScript code,
um,
that It is ideal for scenarios
where you may be actually generating code that you want
to execute yourselves,
um,
that can be provided to a a dynamic worker
loader,
have an execution with,
again, the same performance you get from a worker. So
near zero millisecond cold start
times, um,
to the millisecond, uh, uh,
compute billing,
um, so very attractive for
Both sandboxing use cases, but really that
execution of untrusted, um,
agentically generated code.
Um,
yeah, thank you so much for your time and, uh,
let me know if, if there are any questions about our
offerings.